if you blink you die that's the first  thing you need to know about scp-173  a monstrous living sculpture contained  by the scp foundation a secret  organization dedicated to protecting  humanity from the anomalous also known  as the sculpture the killer statue and  even sometimes the peanut this  unassuming piece of modern art remains  completely still while you're looking at  it however if you look away even for a  fraction of a second the statue will  dart toward you at lightning speeds what  happens if it reaches you simply put the  sculpture will snap your neck with a  nasty crunch its favorite way to  dispatch a victim there's no way to  fight back against scp-173 all you can  do is keep looking and hope you don't  blink that's the only way to survive of  course the average human blinks about 12  times per minute so now ask yourself how  many times have you blinked while  watching this